يلا انزل لك هنكمل البواس احسن
اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم قتيل على الاقل وعشرات
المصابين بين المشجعين نتيجه التدافع في
محيط الملعب الذي يستضيف المباراه
النهائيه في بطوله خليجي 25 بالبصره
جنوبيه العراق ومصدر عراقي يقول ان هناك
حالات حرجه بين المصابين وان العدد مرشح
للارتفاع بسبب الاعداد الكبيره في محيط
الملعب الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يقتل
فلسطينيين اثنين وينفذ حمله اعتقالات في
جنين وبعد اعتقال دام 40 صلاح افرج عن
الاسير الفلسطيني ماهر يونس وان يتنياهو
يقول ان تحركات الفلسطينيين على الساحه
الدوليه هي هجوم على اسرائيل يستدعي الرد
ومصدر امريكي في واشنطن يقول للجزيره ان
واشنطن بعث التحذيرا شديدا لهجه لاسرائيل
من تقويض حل للدولتين بعد دعوه البرلمان
الاوروبيه لادراج الحرس الثوري الايراني
في قائمه المنظمات الارهابيه ايران تنتقد
الخطوه وتحذر من عواقب القرار ومفوض
السياسه الاوروبيه يقول ان القرار يفتقر
للقدره التنفيذيه ويعكس فقط هواجس اوروبا
تسريحه 10,000 موظف خلال العام الجاري ما
يعادل خمسه بالمئه من قوتها العامله وبهذا
تنضم والشركه الى قائمه الشركات
التكنولوجيا التي قررت الاستغناء عن الاف
الموظفين واخفض الانفاق لمواجهه التوقعات
السلبيه التي تواجهها الى اللقاء